right and welcome to this January
meeting of the council my first remind
you of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on it switched on foot booking
tribal training pitch do not re-enter
the building until you're told it is
safe to do so and please switch off your
mobile phones have turned into silent
I'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet capable of repeated viewing the
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you'll be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being filmed by entering this room
you'll also consenting to being filmed
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings
from webcasting and/or training purposes
to council members of the public and the
press may record film or photograph or
broadcasters meeting when the public and
press are not lawfully excluded finally
can members and officers please ensure
you press the red mic the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you're
finished can I move to the agenda please
are you ready Tim item number one
apologies for absence Thank You chair
I've received apologies from councillor
Turner item number two declaration of
interest by councillors are there any
declarations okay moving on to item
number three MC / 19 / 30 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on 24th of
October of 2019 for accuracy only are
there any issues with accuracy
councillor stringer page 8 sorry page
rates yeah where it says paragraph 1514
we it said that we agreed to change
emergency climate change to climate
emergency change actually we're agreed
that it should be climate change
emergency okay cool is that the only one
can I have a proposal for the minutes
please Thank You councillor Brewster can
I have a seconder
Thank You counselor Guthrie all those in
favor that's carried item number for
Chairman's announcements I refer you to
pay for MC / 19 / 31 to be noted writer
number five leaders announcements I
would like to invite counselor Morley to
present her update
Thank You chair happy new year everyone
and welcome back to our council chamber
I hope you'll manage to have at least a
few restful days in the time since we
were last here just before Christmas
Peter Garrett sent out a very
informative update and what has been
done by the public realm team and the
extensive range of day-to-day activities
that the team undertakes Peter also said
that the team will be offering wards to
ward
tours to enable members to see the
team's work at firsthand in their wards
the things that the team does have a
direct and highly visible effect on the
quality of residents lives and there is
growing interest in the management of
our open spaces for well-being and the
environment our proposals for tree
planting and biodiversity corridors will
also mean working directly with our
communities Peter also mentioned a new
five-year program of play site
improvements so please contact Peter
Garrett to arrange a tour and discuss
improvements that you would like to see
in your wards just a reminder that Cape
Panama sent out an email about the
mandatory mandatory equality and
diversity training there are still some
members who are yet to attend and
further dates will be announced soon
this is actually a very good and
enlightening session and I do recommend
it and just to reiterate it is mandatory
and being a Suffolk County councillor or
a place in crime Commissioner
Commissioner does not exempt you from
this
I welcome the discussions held with
counselor Byrne and counselor field to
strengthen our working relationships
between the groups for the good of our
residents we are looking together how
meetings briefings and reports can be
streamlined I met with dr. den last week
and I'm pleased to be able to share I
was pleased to be able to share our
direction of travel and understand in
more detail what government's priorities
are likely to be in the future and I'm
looking forward to informally meeting
along with councillors award Hicks and
Passmore and with fellow public sector
leaders tomorrow and I will be attending
the district council Network conference
to represent mid Suffolk in early
February thank you so attender item six
to receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with council procedure rules
Thank You chair none received number
seven questions by the public in
accordance with council procedure rules
Thank You chair none received some eight
questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure rules none
receive chair gent item nine to receive
reports and cabinet members we've
received plenty of questions in advance
of the meeting is my intention to limit
the discussion of this item to 30
minutes I will therefore draw the
questioning to a close after 30 minutes
is elapsed if the item has not already
been concluded I would like to invite
councillor Mori to introduce this item
yes following discussions with counselor
field and counselor e burn the portfolio
holder reports which come to full counts
or quarterly will in future becoming too
Cavan it also quarterly we have we've
discussed this in quite a bit of detail
and very often we found that the answers
to the questions in the reports are
contained within the performance
monitoring reports that come to cabinet
and so our intention is to expand the
performance monitoring reports to
include some of the detail a more
explanation that is currently in the
portfolio holder reports and that so
this is the last set of portfolio holder
reports that will be coming to for
counsel let's remove on to the questions
I believe counselor Wellum has a
question for the cabinet member for
communities councillor burn I'm sorry
chair I had a question I wanted to ask a
question on the report
MCM u10 from a the we've understand that
we've set aside a million pounds to
mitigate commercial risk for mid suffer
growth and I wanted to understand
whether the portfolio holder thinks that
that is sufficient funding and what was
the decision behind it being a million
pounds thank you Magette reapplying the
I think you're referring to the million
pounds that we are putting in our budget
for this coming year we've also put some
money aside in the past it's pretty much
a question of how long is a piece of
string but the commercial developments
we are undertaking where there be at the
little schools out of paddock I and I
think particularly the gateway 14
development which is obviously going to
be coming to full council in February
that's a very large greenfield site that
we intend to develop and it just feels
prudent to myself that bearing in mind
that for example on that's where it's
fine that's not I'm borrowing that until
such time as we see the fruits of that
starting to come in it's the improvement
to put aside money and not perhaps
recognized so that interest receivable
until such time as we can be totally
assured of the success of the project
but we're going to move to the questions
that we've already had in advance and
the first one I've got is bu Keith to
ask for the councillor for the cabinet
member for Communities Gerry to save
part of the 30 minutes be taken up I
think the questions are all there so
perhaps we could just have the answers
look back in your inbox I think you'll
find it and then the information I'll
fight now is the information was
provided to you in July of last year
shortly after the project was launched
and there is a reference in paragraph
3.9 of my report I'm pleased that you
have given me the opportunity to provide
further detail within MIT Suffolk gisli
and primary school has had initial
meeting as have some boat offs is that
in Potter's tale and sieges and Cedars
Park primary Doran has been in touch to
express interest the furthest ahead are
Freeman York school and Abbott Hall
primaries in snow upland and stone
market who both have action plans in
place the project is focused on helping
these schools increase physical activity
among their students council officers
have I have contacted schools directly
to encourage their involvement and
explain the role of active suffer who
have been commissioned to deliver on
behalf of the council the project is
jointly funded through funding from
public health and directly from the
council's community's budget cancer and
I have three questions here would you
like to read them out so it's on the
film certainly yes um well can I follow
up with that
the important question there was is
there direct involvement in the project
from officers and members is this
something that the schools have been
told about and then they've got to get
on with it because I certainly haven't
had any direct involvement with Freeman
I may now go into the school fairly
frequently I've heard nothing about
active schools in the Freeman school and
so up so I would like to know whether
whether officers are involved and if
they are encouraging members to become
involved I'm not sure I had an answer to
how is the project funded the next
question was could we have an update on
the proposed Park run in stone market
please have negotiations on use of the
land for the Chilton fields route being
completed or has another route being
considered and could we have an update
on the leisure strategy
in particular the strategy for providing
leisure services in remote areas thank
you back to the schools it has been
commissioned as active suffer have been
commissioned by funding okay
so basic it's a three year program and
what what has happened to schools can
have extra help to deliver sport where
they haven't got that specialism but
it's about how they get to school if
they walk to school what they do in
class if they get up and have a run
about in between maths so it's a little
bit of everyday activity as long along
with the sports if you'd like to go in
and you know I'm sure we can arrange
that but we have commissioned active
supper to take that wrong and we put 50
thousand into that
and your next answer on the public park
run
okay public realm officers have taken
the lead on this project and met with
councilor Mansell last week all Saturday
morning uses of Chilton fields have now
been contacted seeking confirmation that
prepares timing would not conflict with
any existing activities on the site
including football rugby and cricket
clubs each of these groups have been
advised that councillor Mansell would be
a the Event Director and that all of the
park ground volunteers are keen to look
at and address any potential issues ie
bottleneck points by walking the route
as part of the site meeting Sarah has
also met made all groups aware that
councillor Manson is in discussion with
the other local sites about potential
local parking for Park ground
participants nearby but not at the
children Hills field as parking is one
of the concerns raised a face-to-face
meeting is being set up with the clubs
in the next three weeks the index
farmers the leisure strategy providing
leisure services in remote areas the
leisure sport and physical activity
distraction strategy LS pas delivery has
focused on redeveloping and refurbishing
the council's own main leisure centres
in stone markets travel these are invest
to save projects that when complete will
generate annual revenue savings to the
council an element of which will be used
to establish resourcing within the
communities team to develop the proposed
outreach programs negotiations are
currently underway with everyone active
to agree not only the redevelopment
refurbishments of the leisure centres
but also to consider their proposals to
provide a community outreach resource
the detail of their proposals is now
being considered to establish their
delivery program which is a new role for
them and currently due to commence from
the start of their new contract in
October 2020 subject to the relevant
approvals another important project
supporting provision in more remote
areas is the active well-being project
referred to at paragraph 3.8 of my
report delivery in mid Suffolk has been
focused around fessing field and
straggler dead numb and I i won't
rehearse the information provided within
the report in answer this question but
impact is being monitored and the
further information is available on the
website in your papers and on that note
I'd like to please welcome to our team
Vicki Moseley and she now becomes the
new corporate manager for communities
and thinking stand up so everybody knows
who to come I hope that makes us at
capacity now does it talk yeah right
next question
I'm counselor Mel and I believe you've
got two questions for the cabinet member
for the environment yes I'll crack on
with assuming no I hate us to miss out
on the last question from Barry
Humphries at the end of the list in the
report it talks about scoping out a new
way step aside and the question I have
is has gateway 14 been considered as a
potential location for the new demo
thank you for question counselor yes it
is being considered along with two other
sites let's come back with a
supplementary would the teller would the
cabinet member agree with me that
gateway 14 presents a wonderful
opportunity to integrate energy
generation and trial net new
technologies such as hydrogen generation
from solar PV and even from wind power
with the potential to power our waste
collection vehicles as has been trialing
elsewhere in the country and yes I
absolutely do agree with you and I would
like to see some really innovative
projects coming to this site
aspirationally even perhaps some looking
at hydrogen battery techno
and you know some of the more
adventurous things that we really should
be looking at so yes indeed thank you
for that answer
and moving on noting that mid suffix
membership of the Suffolk climate change
partnership has resulted in a number of
properties benefiting from the bulk
buying scheme will there be a further
round of the scheme in 2020 and could
this game be widened to include pratt
solar hot water panels the scheme then
is currently running but the the period
for registering with the current opening
period ended on the 17th of January so
we there the next possible opening is
going to probably be in August but I
have spoken to solar together and they
can't confirm it's actually when that
will be
but it usually happens twice a year so
we're expecting a summer opportunity for
and the group buying participation in
terms of thermal hot water generation at
the moment that is not being offered
through solar together I have spoken to
them and if enough interest is expressed
from not just from us obviously but from
around the country then that may be
something they'll offer in the future
but it's not offered at the moment I'm
canceller Humphreys I believe you have a
question
come on chair thank you before we begin
obviously is a typo on the questions in
regards to my name I know what's more
annoying is it's not my full title which
cause Mary Barry Humphries but now you
all know me I'll go on with a question
as most councillors be aware the
Forestry Commission runs tree-planting
grunt schemes and the government also
runs the urban tree planting scheme
please can you reassure me and obviously
the other councillors that the climate
emergency Task Force is fully
considering the issue of tree coverage
in mid Suffolk and how best to identify
land suitable
hunting and then fund the planting of
more trees a lot comes this second
question after your answer thank you yes
Thank You councillor Humphries yes the
task force is taking in tree planting
very seriously and is committing to
improve tree coverage in the district we
aware of the grant schemes and the
funding available and I would point out
that the urban tree Challenge Fund grant
is for 50% of the cost of firm planting
the remainder has to be found to a match
funding process so it's not as if the
grant for a place for all of it
we're currently assessing the criteria
for how these funds can be used and
utilized in mid Suffolk once the
assessment is complete we will be
looking at opportunities to bring
forward land and part of the task force
work is of course to identify where in
what land is suitable for tree planting
and I think because it is we're looking
particularly at the urban tree challenge
we're aware that trees in urban areas
perform a lot of useful tasks cleaning
up the air and providing shade etc etc
so we will be looking at areas like snow
market and some of our other terms
market towns - where additional trees
could be usefully introduced further
tree planting initiatives will be
discussed at the next task force won't
you thank you the second question and
thank you councillor Mellon forum give
me time to answer ask this one since the
creation of the etg what projects have
been started and what projects do you
have in mind an immediate future right
and we have indefinitely
really started any projects per se the
perhaps of the task force is to identify
projects get funding get the cabinet
approval get funding for them and and
get them in place as soon as possible
but obviously projects that need funding
need to be approved through the cabinet
process we have so far met and discussed
energy building design and biodiversity
and the next item on our agenda to
discuss is transport and waste that's
coming up in February in terms of what
we've actually done we have commissioned
a baseline survey of emissions in mid
Suffolk and this has been conducted by
groundwork we are also working closely
with Suffolk County Council and the work
they're doing through a company called
Ricardo which is a Suffolk wide
assessment of carbon emissions because
obviously they work the districts needs
to fit in with the work of the county
and to be done in a comfortable way
we're looking at scopes one two and
three emissions so we are looking as
widely as possible at the environmental
impact of our activities we will be
looking at recommendations for actions
to address areas of high emissions once
we get that some day so we will probably
be focusing on a couple of areas that we
expect to be recommended for our
attention and investment Thank You
councillor Meston I believe you have a
question for the cabinet member for
finance yes thank you
noting that our staff and members of the
Suffolk wide local authorities pension
scheme is our representative pressing
for divestment from all fossil fuel
investments bearing in mind our plan
exclaiming projective respond yes thank
you looks like castle they're months in
the first question just bit of
background in 2009 I was appointed as a
trustee of the separate pension fund to
represent all the district and Borough
Council's
in Suffolk so that means not any miss
effort but also West Suffolk he suffered
a brain of switch and the pension fund
exists to pay the pension benefits of
over 60,000 members whether 300 separate
employees in the fund and invests over 3
billion pounds patient from monies and
the committee has a fiduciary duty to
protect and target and approximate risk
adjusted investment return and because
it's a defined benefit scheme any
shortfall arising from performance or
from funding has to be met by the
employers and therefore ultimately the
risk and any additional cost is that of
our council taxpayers so the committee
invest money in a wide range of assets
for the divided diverse set of
investment managers to discharge that
producer duty we've got to active in
equity managers though it has to it
outperform their respective indices by
selecting and holding shares which they
believe will outperform and that process
involves been taking to accountable
information available including climate
change it also invests equity through
passive investment first funds and these
invest in all the shares in a given
index to guarantee returns in line
without Marvel but recently the
committee transfer just under 40% of
that passive equity investments into a
climate to where
passive fund and they've done that
without faltering than expected
investment return so I feel this
demonstrates the committee's commitment
to taking climate change into account
while still firmly meeting its fiduciary
duty responsibilities and also both
through its investment managers combined
membership of the local authority
pension fund forum the committee engaged
with all the companies in which you
directly invests to improve in
mental social and governance practices
and of course such dialogue includes
with those companies in adopting how
they look at effective climate change
Thank You councillor Mansoor we've got a
question for the cabinet member for
housing Thank You chair um yeah I did
send in three questions for the cabinet
member for housing but as I'm the new
structure of this meeting has only just
been explained to me could first of all
could I ask how do I ask any other
questions other than the three I'm only
to think of before today at the end
after all the other questions have been
answered it would have been it would
have been more helpful if we knew that
this was going to be the format
beforehand I feel very stifled by having
a time limit when some of the answers
are quite long and some of the questions
are quite short and I feel it's a little
bit unfair if I am restricted from our
three questions because some of the
answers are quite lengthy
well anyway my first question to the
cabinet member for housing is about the
proportion of Universal Credit
recipients who have alternative payment
agreements this appears to have risen in
the last six months from approximately
58 percent over 70 percent firstly am I
correct that this method is used only to
clear rent arrears and is there anything
that we as a council are doing or can do
to ensure that this figure does not
continue to rise and to help those
claimants money to their budgets and
future Thank You councillor Mansell
alternative payment arrangement
arrangements or a pas have increased in
line with the number of our tenants who
are in receipt of universal credit and
are in rent arrears as the rollout of
the Universal Credit continues we would
also expect to see an increase in the
number of APA APA
can be used for tenants who are not in
rent arrears for example where there are
addiction problems mental health mental
health issues learning difficulties or
they were previously homeless
however we normally only request an APA
if the tenant is in arrears and the
decision will follow a discussion within
tenants once an APA is in place the rent
account will be regularly reviewed and
contact made with the tenant as the
tenant gets closer to clearing their
arrears we would discuss with them
ending the APA some tenants may feel
confident that they will be able to
manage once the arrangement comes to an
end but others may prefer to continue
for a time regard to regarding budgetary
support for claimants when a tenant
first moves on to you the universal
credit their work coach will refer them
for budgeting support the income offices
will also discuss with the tenants and
Kate and can make further referrals if
required this might be to teams within
the council such as the tenancy support
offices or to external open
organizations such as Citizens Advice
step change or homegroup the income team
have also started calling all new
tenants within the first two weeks of
their tenancy
this has allowed us to identify issues
much earlier and provide support before
rent arrears become unmanageable the
benefits of this approach include the
opportunity to build rap rapid sorry
rapport with new tenants making sure the
tenants know who to go to if they get
into difficulties with their rent and
assisting with universal credit claims
okay could I just come back oh yeah I
understand completely that the number of
people who are on alternative payment
agreements will rise with the number of
people who are on universal credit I
completely understand that but my
question was about the fact that the
percentage of those people on Universal
who are in receipt of a pas is going up
it's not rising with it it is rising
faster than the rise of people on
universal credit and that's what concern
to me in that question shall I go on to
my other question the other two
questions that I have a much shorter
questions but who knows how long the
answers are going to be are there any
future plans to provide more properties
for the staying close project with
Suffolk County Council and my other one
which is quite sure I may as well do it
now what is the timeline for presenting
the business case for the joint venture
building service program to either
cabinet or Council and maybe you can
confirm which it to be okay thank you
there are the council is working closely
with Suffolk County Council to
understand all of their house and
requirements not only for staying closed
but also for other client groups
including those with specialist
accommodation needs such as learning
disabilities we have a meeting scheduled
to discuss what their needs are and
agree what is feasible for mid Suffolk
to assist with it is important we work
closely with SCC particularly around our
corporate parenting responsibilities but
we also need to balance the demand
through the housing register and those
households currently placed in temporary
accommodation your next question and the
timeline like working this is with our
joint venture mm-hmm
work is ongoing in developing the legal
framework for which the joint venture
would operate within this involves
separate legal advice on employment and
tax work is ongoing in ensuring that the
financials with respect to the current
service and the cost of the JV are
comparable and robust regular updates to
staff in the form of meetings weekly
newsletters a restructure of the service
to align it with our aspirations going
forward a review of our contract with
blue flame who are a member of the
flagship group
wider awareness the involvement through
shadowing and I'm going out with the
team next week huge amounts of effort in
developing current service delivery this
has included in interim management and
improvements such as renegotiating our
materials contract and identifying new
ways of working for staff that improves
productive as well as employee
satisfaction so I haven't got the answer
to the timeline because this is taken up
a little bit more time to get it right
before it comes to cabinet but we are
working very closely with flagship at
the moment to try and get everything in
place I don't know we've Gavin's got any
more on that but we are going ahead with
everything as planned and I can confirm
that just by getting involved with
flagship at this time our savings on
materials are fantastic because of the
buying power so we're already seeing the
benefit of our actually trying to come
to an agreement on how it's all going to
work so it already benefiting on the
ground on the work front if you like
Thank You councillor chair just in
regards to timeline we're still working
on a timeline in which we bring a report
back to cabinet in May or June at the
latest I did update the administration
at briefing only in the last sort of two
months where we were able to discuss the
the plans and some of the challenges
that we're currently got in developing
that um thank you um councillor Mason
you've got a question for the yes I'd be
very I'd be very happy to just have
drawn though the the question for the
attention of the to portfolio holders
and I look forward to hearing in due
course what the answers are but don't no
need to try and do it today
okay councillor scarf you've got a
question for the cabinet member for
planning
yes think Jack as a member of the joint
capsule planning Charter Review Group
which has only met once on August the
6th can you advise as to progress on
this issue my understanding was the
officers would be looking at a merging
of the two separate planning charters
and reporting back to the reboot group
with the draft combined Charter so the
members could come in as the next stage
in the process thank you for your
question dr. Scott um since the original
meeting of the working group in August
significant work has been undertaken to
review the Charter taking into account
examples of best practice from other
local authorities as such a draft has
now been completed and has been sent to
the cabinet members for planning for
comment before G is presented to the
working group it has taken longer than
anticipated to conduct this work due to
the general election where democratic
service services officers worked to help
ensure the election ran smoothly with
regards to the proposed visits to other
councils that's member visits to other
council to see how they operate these
were also delayed by the election as the
other as the Democratic Services teams
were heavily involved in the election
and advised that they could not
facilitate a visit at that time to
showcase their best best practice
however the Democratic services team are
currently at organizing the visits to
other councils and members will be
invited to these shortly once these
visits have taken place the formal
meeting of the working group will be
organized I will be meeting with my
fellow portfolio holder from Baber on
the 11th of February
with the monitoring officer and chief
planning officer to reveal their
progress on this and to discuss the
potential to agree common ground in
relation to key topics within the
Charter in order to assist the prompt
work of the review councillor Byrne you
have a question um thank you very much
chair and firstly I think it's very
disappointing that given the words of
our leader councillor Morley talking
about cooperation between groups that
we've had this restriction placed upon
us at the meeting and not being advised
of it in advance in life I please ask
you madam chairman that that doesn't
happen again and then future that we're
if you're changing any structure of this
council meeting that we actually have
some cont liaison between the group
leaders please I do have a question
really about neighborhood plans and the
support for them many of our communities
have got neighborhood plans in place and
as the joint local plan is becoming more
developed it'll be get to the stage
where the joint local plan is made and
the neighborhood hands need reviewing so
have we've got enough staff in place to
support our neighborhood plan groups to
ensure that they can review their
neighborhood plans to make sure that
they fit with the joint local plan as
that's progressing thank you very much
thank you I have to admit that I'm not
aware of the situation to staffing on
that particular issue I don't know
whether
well Tom might be able to assist us with
that one yeah and sure answer yes that
does depend upon how much support
individual groups need and want and it's
our role to support not to write on
behalf of so where there are particular
communities that anticipate a level of
resource from the council that is
essentially writing the plan on their
behalf we won't be doing that for them
but we do have bespoke resource in the
form of Paul who's there to help
coordinate and organize and help point
signpost people but we've also embedded
across the entire planning policy team
that offices there from the senior
officers through we'll be there to
support people we've been supporting
with mapping and other things and we've
just recovered our GIS specialists so
that we're able to provide that support
as well right I've had and now the
half-hour is up but I've got three more
people with questions that we're gonna
have then starts me counselor Mansell
Thank You chair I have one question for
the portfolio for planning and one for
environment if if that's allowed in your
report for the planning portfolio holder
is section 4.1 refers to the planning
referrals meeting that we have next
Wednesday and I'm a little concerned and
I have had comments from members of the
public sent to me regarding the fact
that we'll have over a thousand pages to
read and digest in a week and this is a
very large task and I think really you
know it would have been nicer how come
you know it's very going to be very
difficult for us so was there any way
that we could have had a little bit more
notice so we had time I don't think
we're going to give our communities
justice that is my question for planning
shall I do that one and then come back
with the environment why not do them at
the same time right and my question for
the portfolio holder for environment is
about the new packaging materials
manufacturers are being encouraged well
they seem to be branding them as
environmentally friendly and calling
them compostable packaging but we here
in mid Suffolk and I don't think we're
alone do not have the facilities to
compost these so-called compostable
packages and it's a case of are we
informing our population but you can't
put these in your brown bin you can't
put them on a compost heap and and
similarly follow-on from that are we in
mid stuff we're going to do anything
about getting an industrial composter so
that we can deal with these compostable
waste or are we campaigning with
government that these things should not
be branded as being environmentally
friendly okay David stop well I guess
I'll make a start on that one or the one
you asked me that was the capacity of
committee members and so on and and and
the public to digest a thousand pages
report for a particular planning meeting
I think the person best qualified is not
myself but a member or a chair of the
Planning Committee Guthrie if she'd give
her views on that please yes well I
recall the last time we had the Thurston
meeting I've just actually looked it up
it was nineteen hundred and eighty five
pages and we actually had a planning B
in the morning as well it is extremely
difficult it's extremely challenging but
equally all planning committees the
papers are published and then you have
that week so it is very very difficult
and I will be discussing that with
councillor Hicks and various the chief
executives and so on regarding comments
that we have been received but it is
normal to have only that time break that
time frame and we do well I certainly
try and read them as best I can and I
know you do you're very diligent with it
and they are indeed but you know that's
the response at the moment and we will
be looking at things further Thank You
councillor Fleming which would actually
answer and I'm her second question thank
you thank you cancer in men so I think
you have actually asked me this
previously and I think the answer
probably isn't exactly what you expected
or what you wished for I think Suffolk
West
Partnership officers are best positioned
to answer it precisely because I am not
in a position to answer it at the moment
there's a fine line between what's
compostable most biodegradable and the
labeling on packages is really a
national issue of Beyond and I think
this is not something for me to answer
in this chamber Thank You councillor
often you have a question yes thank you
Karen first of all I have some sympathy
with members who feel that this session
has been cut short but quite frankly I
think it would be much better if
obviously the cabinet members have got
their answers that was actually printed
and given to the members because many of
those answers were very comprehensive
not about others I know I'm getting old
and grumpy but I am you know one can't
always take it away
I mean we've quite useful to them to
have some supplementary question so I'm
assuming that now I can ask questions on
the actual reports in the cup in the cup
in their council papers yeah okay
my first question then is to the Jessica
Fleming on your report 3.3 states work
ten years on the national waste strategy
officers are working on
appraisals and potential new service
delivery models accessing future
infrastructure needs and what exactly
does that mean place on page 61 to the
planning cabinet member I'd like to know
why it is that the council is now
dismissing the fact that it now has a 5
year loan supply in their argument to
refuse planning permissions in advance
developers have used the fact that the
council did not have a 5 year land
supply to persuade the council to agree
to numerous large planning applications
it now seems that the council is saying
oh that fact that we have a 5.7 housing
supply is now considered immaterial
thank you and finally my question I'm
not sure whether that should go to the
councilor chair of scrutiny but I'll do
it now because I believe it is also to
the leader of the council are you fully
aware of the conditions that are being
imposed on the possible reduction of
funding for citizens and vice bureaus
and the possible reduction in the number
of camp za bees across suffered from
Fortis from 7 to 4 and will you be
signing those conditions thank you do
you want to start councillor firming yes
thank you thank you for your question
and it is it is a slightly bureaucratic
sounding paragraph I agree but trying to
draw out what is really means actually
the national waste strategy is a very
important matter and the government is
going to be consulting well it is
in this various stages some of the early
stages have already happened on various
changes to her waist nationally will be
managed I think the objective overall is
to try to do to make the the waist
throughout the country more consistent
such that you know food waste collection
is is universally done throughout the
country etc however it's very early
stages and we're looking at you know
responding to consultations we expect to
come up in the next year on things like
whether we should collect food waste
whether we should collect glass at the
curbside and that sort of thing if and
when those consultations come to us that
I think this chamber will be making some
very important decisions or
recommendations more likely on what we
should be doing in the interests of the
country and and of course the county in
the district so that that's all I can
say about it now but I would recommend
that anyone who's interested in this
topic and we probably all are to keep an
eye on the government's website and
become familiar with with the thought
process behind what we can see coming to
us council of burma try to answer the
second part of the question or the
second question
pretty land supply I didn't understand
that question counselor what do you mean
by dismissing the factories but a five
valence blow I don't understand in the
past when the council did not have a
five-year land supply the council
council members on the Planning
Committee were told we cannot refuse
planning applications because the Deluth
developers will appeal because the
council hasn't got a five year land
supply council now has a 5.7 housing
land supply and yet I believe there are
certain recommendations in planning
committee that says actually we cannot
take that all into consideration that is
not a major consideration okay
yes I understand a little better now it
the situation is quite complicated and
the combination of factors that they
used to determinate planning
applications sometimes do involve this
lucky land supply and sometimes
depending on other circumstances they do
not however I would rather pass this
question to an expert in the matter of
myself and I would ask mr. Isabel minded
explaining what I can't explain
thank you yes the situation is
unfortunately a complicated one it was
traditionally the case that finally land
supply was the the answer to that
question of whether or not the
presumption in favor of sustaining yeah
it was engaged that changed in the
recent the most recent iteration of the
national policy framework and now it is
more than that one must have a plan that
is up-to-date and the unfortunate thing
is that the Kaos strategy from 2008 is
not considered to be up-to-date and the
outcome of various appeal decisions have
pointed in that direction the end result
with this is that develops are
continuing to come forward with schemes
and as Council billboard outs a test
from the experience that's going on this
week in the public inquiry and I the
importance of having an up-to-date plan
comes back fully front and center to the
question of determining applications in
accordance with a plan so to that extent
the presumption in favor of sustainable
development must guide comity and indeed
we had councils attend a council attend
this week for a member training exercise
around both land supply and naval
planning issues which was organized
specifically to try and provide more
clarity for all members on the issues of
land supply and that presumption in
favor of sustainable development Thank
You councillor Morley would you like to
reply about the CIB yes at its cabinet
meeting a couple of weeks ago we agreed
funding to the CIB of three years worth
of 86 thousand pounds each year we have
not provided we have not demanded any
conditions on those we've actually gone
10 minutes over the half hour John field
has got one more question which I mean
let him are asked it's not you that are
demanding conditions I think there is a
joint agreement across the County
Council
I can't answer for the county council
council feel would you like to ask your
question this is the last question I
think you'll be overjoyed to hear that
Casa Mesa stole my question she's very
unreasonable behavior much more brief
than you returned it I would just make
the point that the answers I didn't
think were terribly satisfactory now a
thousand pages is probably 15 hours
reading might be 30 hours reading it's
often quite complex English which is
difficult to decode on a complex subject
and we are it to our residents to do
that job properly so I am certainly
pretty unhappy about that commitment and
you know the port's all parties my line
that withdraw in your labor was always a
good method of responding in a sort of
slightly socialist right so one might
facilitate you know because we really
shouldn't get into this sort of
positions more residents in my residence
it's actually John wattage residents in
Bahrein and now they're also pretty fed
out that I will get very little time to
read to adjust the data before making a
decision so sorry that was a statement
not a question there you go okay moving
on set agenda item 10 overview and
scrutiny committee report I'd like to
invite councillor Welland to introduce
his report which is just for noting
thank you chair as you see we had three
separate meetings on the 8th of January
and I have only reported on one of those
I only had about 48 hours to do so but I
have put together this one because I
feel it is important that you understand
you have the opportunity to read about
the cross authority task and finish
group on Citizens Advice a couple things
I'd like to draw members attention to
and that is that I feel it's in poor
and that it's Suffolk District Council
do not interfere in any way with the
service that is provided there was
concern with members around members
within the task and finish group that
there were conditions being placed by
Suffolk County Council on the the
Citizens Advice bureaux to reorganize
but we we discussed that to a degree and
we felt that the office in stone market
is well-run it's important to proper to
point that out they have already taken
opportunities for efficiency savings and
they're looking at more as our other
Citizens Advice bureaux looking at ways
of making efficiency savings setting
conditions and interfering could well
lead to the loss of volunteers we've
heard that that volunteers feel that
they are members of a group working in a
particular Bureau and to try to
interfere we felt would be
counterproductive I'm happy to take any
questions does anyone have any questions
for councillor ellen councillor stringer
yeah I have two questions for the chair
of scrutiny I probably would have asked
them within the questions to portfolio
holders that you can push democracy back
but it will pop up somewhere else
when we finally get to scrutinizing the
costs of the move from Needham Market
and Hadley into this glass edifice in it
which could we make sure that the unn
forecast cost of Skype etc is actually
looked at in detail as to how a business
case can be put in front of members with
such a glaring error in it and and all
of the financial consequences are taken
into the round can I also our scrutiny
to look at that we get 24-hour or at
least 360 days a year cover in cases
where a tree officer needs to
attend a tree about to be felled that
isn't a subject to a TPO
but would have been when the threat was
known we have this bizarre situation in
this country where the law doesn't allow
you to protect a tree unless it's
already got a teepee oh it's in a
conservation area or it is about to be
threatened either by a planning
application or by somebody with a
chainsaw if we don't have the cover from
our tree offices to attend on the day
the chainsaw arrives then we will have
what exactly what happened dimensional
green where we lose a 200 year old cedar
tree for which the farm erected
afterwards was named so can I be assured
that scrutiny will look at that to make
sure we have that cover three hundred
and sixty days a year can you give an
assurance to that council away
I'm talking out of the first question
first the cost of the move scrutiny did
attempt to look into the some scrutiny
of the cost of the move but we were told
that it was too complicated and not all
of the information was there for us to
come to a conclusion and so we were
persuaded that rather than waste time
going round and round and there never
being able to get to an answer that
that's it was left in the bench we were
never going to get a definitive answer
on the cost of the move what whether
there were savings or whether there was
extra expenditure we felt that it was
costing more to have moved then it would
have been if we'd stayed where we were
but we could not prove that and officers
couldn't give us the information to
prove the opposite either so I'm afraid
that we can't do that one particular
aspect of the move yes it may well be
possible to look at that whether it's a
matter for a full scrutiny meeting or
not I will I will discuss that with with
the council and with and with offices
and the cover for tree or three of us I
feel that it is important that the
offices and the cabinet member
have an opportunity to sort that one out
first but we don't I'd rather it didn't
come to Scouten here's a problem but
rather that the cabinet member cabinet
and offices bought to be able to come to
an arrangement whereby there is cover
and then select to that scrutiny know
what the answer is
moving on to agenda item 11
the botticella McCann home neighborhood
development plan I'd like to invite
counselor Byrne to introduce paper MC
slash 1934 and to move the
recommendations in the report the report
before you updates the Council on the
local referendum held on the bosses Dale
and Ricky Hall neighborhood plan in
light of the declared result it
recommends that this plan be formally
adopted work on the plan commenced in
mid 2017 it has been through the
appropriate public consultation stages
and has been independently examined it
is fit for purpose and will enable
planning officers to make informed
decisions on applications within the
designated area the local referendum
took place on the 28th of November and
as set out in paragraph 4.3 of the
report the declared result was as
follows the total number of votes cast
forty four hundred and thirty three
which was a twenty five point eight
percent turnout the number of yes votes
cast was 377 that's eighty seven point
one percent of those who voted and
number of no votes was 56 12.9% of the
well there were no void ballot papers
and the total number of persons entitled
to vote was 1678 paragraph 4.6 refers to
the appended draft decision statement a
copy of this will be sent to the parish
clerk and be published on our website in
2019 this council adopted five
neighborhood plans covering the parishes
of de belem Stradbroke Stowe upland holy
and Thurston the decision today sees the
bottles dáil and drinking whole
neighborhood plan become the seventh to
be formally adopted to date we have 17
other neighborhood plans being
progressed across the district a number
of which may come before the council for
adoption as this year as the year
progresses I would like to congratulate
all those involved in getting this plan
to the adoption stage and I asked the
council to endorse a recommendation
before it I look at the seconder for
that motion
do we have a seconder thank
but twelve counselor appointment
counselor Morley I believe if you have
some changes to placings yes thank you
chair I have some changes to the shared
revenues partnership I wish to appoint a
counselor Brewster and counselor Fleming
has named substitutes joining myself and
counselor Whitehead on the shared
revenues partnership cabinet
appointments I'm really pleased to
announce that Peter Gould will be taking
up the cabinet position of assets and
investments immediately and I'm also
really excited to welcome and counselor
Harry Richardson to the front bench as a
Cabot cabinet member without portfolio
and again that's effective immediately
there's result and as a result of Harry
joining the front bench I'm really
pleased to announce that councilor
Caston will be replacing Harry on the
planning committee thank you are there
any further changes could I have a
proposal and could I have a seconder
happy to sit in that chair
thank you that's just the book of the
Mitte places not the cabinet all those
in favor and those against
those abstaining that's carry right now
that some that's it and the date of the
next meeting is Thursday the 27th of our
February at 5:30 thanks very much bye oh
sorry it's just I've just noticed I was
put in putting at least a all the dates
of all the full council meetings in my
diary through 2021 cause obviously none
of us want to miss any I noticed that
I've been given the 22nd of October as a
meeting which is the same day as another
authority support council in the same
chamber and I think the chance for then
finishing by 5:00 5:30 we did have
another an email about this last week
saying which have it on the Monday
Gentry how'd you do it I mean two emails
okay counselor man so hang on I'm sorry
I don't recall having an email on Monday
about a change of a day so I'm sorry it
hasn't been out to email all right all
right I had one